Once Upon a midnight dreary while I
pondered weak and weary over many quaint
and curious volume of Forgotten lore
while I nodded nearly napping suddenly
there came a tapping as of someone
gently rapping rapping at my chamber
door tis some visitor I muttered tapping
at my chamber door only this and nothing
more
ah distinctly I remember it was in the
Bleak December and each separate dying
ember wrought its ghost upon the floor
eagerly I wished the morrow vainly I had
sought to borrow from my books surcease
of sorrow sorrow for the lost Lenore for
the rare and radiant maiden whom the
angel's name Lenore nameless here for
evermore and the silken sad uncertain
rustling of each purple curtain thrilled
me filled me with fantastic terrors
never felt before so that now to still
the beating of my heart I stood
repeating tis some visitor entreating
entrance at my chamber door some late
visitor entreating entrance at my
chamber door this is it and nothing more
presently my soul grew stronger
hesitating then no longer sir said I or
madam truly your forgiveness I know but
the fact is I was napping and so gently
you came rapping and so faintly you came
tapping tapping at my chamber door that
I scarce was sure I heard you here I
opened wide the door darkness there and
nothing wrong deep into that darkness
peering long I stood there wondering
fearing doubting dreaming dreams no
mortal ever dared to dream before but
the silence was unbroken and the
stillness gave no token and the only
word there spoken was the whispered word
Lenore this I whispered and an echo
murmured back the word Lenore merely
this and nothing more back into the
chamber turning all my soul within me
burning soon again I heard a tapping
somewhat louder than before surely said
I surely that is something at my window
lattice let me see then what thereat is
and this mystery explore let my heart be
still a moment and this mystery explore
is the wing and nothing more open here I
flung the shutter when with many a flirt
and a flutter in there stepped a stately
Raven of the saintly days of yore not
the least obeisance made he not a minute
stopped or stayed me but with mien of
Lord or lady
perched above my chamber door perched
upon a bust of Pallas just above my
chamber door perched and sat and nothing
more then this ebony bird beguiling my
sad fancy into smiling by the grave and
stern decorum of the countenance it wore
though thy crest be shorn and shaven
thou I said art sure no Craven ghastly
grim and ancient Raven wandering from
the nightly Shore tell me what thy
lordly name is on the night's Plutonian
Shore quoth the raven nevermore much i
marvelled this ungainly fowl day
disclose certainly though its answer
little meaning--little relevancy for for
we cannot help agreeing that no living
human being ever yet was blessed with
seeing bird above his chamber door bird
or beast upon the sculptured bust above
his chamber door with such a name as
Nevermore but the Raven sitting lonely
on the Placid bust spoke only that one
word as if his soul in that one word he
did outpour nothing farther then he
uttered not a feather and he fluttered
till I scarcely more than muttered other
friends have flown before
on the morrow he will leave me as my
hopes have flown before then the Bird
said Nevermore
startled that the stillness broken by
reply so aptly spoken doubtless said i
what it utters is its only stock and
store caught from some unhappy master
whom unmerciful disaster followed fast
and followed faster till his songs one
burden or till the dirges of his hope
that melancholy burden bore of never
Nevermore but the Raven still beguiling
all my fancy into smiling straight I
wheeled a cushioned seat in front of
bird and bust and door then upon the
velvet sinking I betook myself to
linking fancy unto fancy thinking what
this ominous bird of yore what this grim
ungainly ghastly gaunt and ominous bird
of yore meant in croaking Nevermore this
i sat engaged in guessing but no
syllable expressing to the fowl whose
fiery eyes now burned into my bosoms
call this as well
i sat divining with my head at ease
reclining on the cushions velvet lining
that the lamplight gloated o'er but
whose velvet violet lining with the
lamplight gloating o'er she shall press
ah Nevermore then we thought the air
grew denser perfumed from an unseen
censer swung by Seraphim whose footfalls
tinkled on the tufted floor wrench i
cried thy god hath lent thee by these
angels he hath sent thee respite respite
and
the pinzhi of thy memories of lenore
graph a graph this kind Nepenthe and
forget this lost Lenore quoth the raven
nevermore prophet said I thing of evil
prophet still if bird or devil whether
tempter sent or whether tempest tossed
thee here ashore desolate yet all
undaunted on this desert land enchanted
on this home by horror haunted tell me
truly I implore is that is there balm in
Gilead tell me tell me I implore quoth
the raven nevermore
prophet said I thing of evil prophet
still if bird or devil by that heaven
that bends above us by that God we both
adore tell this soul with sorrow laden
if within the distant aidenn it shall
clasp a sainted maiden whom the angels
name lenore clasp a rare and radiant
maiden whom the angels name lenore quoth
the raven nevermore be that word our
sign of parting bird or fiend i shrieked
upstarting get me back to the tempest
and the night's plutonian shore leave no
black plume as a token of that lie thy
soul hath spoken
leave my loneliness unbroken quit the
bust above my door take thy beak from
out my heart and take thy form from off
my door
boy if the raven nevermore
and the Raven never flitting still is
sitting still is sitting on the pallid
bust of Pallas just above my chamber
door and his eyes have all the seeming
of a demons that is dreaming and the
lamplight o'er him streaming throws his
shadow on the floor and my soul from out
that shadow that lies floating on the
floor shall be lifted Nevermore I would
like to give a special thank you to
research her Brandon Connell Burlington
the cut slump god Justin Day Pierce M
Hamlin white crew
beware 600 Bryson V Lee my archive
curator Nick Tiger bull Cody tench
cheese weapon the Android the
administrator quartz 5 6 3 on tree hero
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos on some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the vulcan
thank you
[Music]
you